قطعه مني كيف حتى الحين ابكي علي ولدي
والله كل شويه ابكي بس الحمد لله
بهذه الكلمات المؤثره تحدث مصطفى الصفواني
والد الشاب حمزه الذي توفي في مدينه
انطاكيا التركيه تحدث لكاميرا العربيه حول
تفاصيل وفاته جراء الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب المدينه انا قبل اربع ايام
اربع ايام عزيت خلاص
قبل الزلزال والله والله والله والله
في نفس الليله وانا قاعد على سجادتي قبل
الفجر قلت ان شاء الله اجيب ولدي قبل لا
يصير شي مشاكل هناك تركيا بيجي بيجي ان
شاء الله بس بعد القطاوه
الحمد لله هذا الاب كان ينتظر عوده ابنه
الى حضنه بعد غيابه لسنوات طويله حيث عاش
حمزه مع والدته في سوريا قبل ان ينتقل الى
تركيا قبل عامين تمهيدا لعودته الى عائله
ابيه في صفوه شرقيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
يشبهها اطباع اخواني بالضبط
حتى حركاته
ابدا يعني امس جاي احنا في القبر ومسوي
عزا في الليل
نفس فكروا اخوه جواهر اللي توفى هو جواد
يلا استاذ في مدرسه اليرموك
لاني يشبهوا الحمد لله الله يعطيه والله
ياخذ تقريبا قبل شهر كان تواصل معاي
والحمد لله رب العالمين على كل حال ما
نقدر نقول الا غير الحمد لله كنا نترقب
جيته في اقرب وقت ممكن
بس ان شاء الله
وشاءت الاقدار والحمد لله على كل حال ما
نقدر نقول غير الحمد لله
ما تواصل مع ابنه المتوفي قبل ايام قليله
من رحيله مبينا انه كان يعيش برفقه جدته
من امه في انطاكيا التي نجت باعجوبه من
الزلزال بعد اخراجها من تحت الانقاض راحه
يوم الجمعه في الصباح راحوا والله وفتش
اللي شافوا هذه شافوا
مهدك ظاهره جدته ظاهر راسها
وقعدوا يحفروا فراوله طلعوها في ودوها
المستشفى الحمد لله ما فيها اشي
حمزه قال توفى
الحمد لله
حمزه ليس الابن الوحيد الذي فقد حياته في
عائله مصطفى هناك ابن اخر له توفي غرقا
قبل عده سنوات بمدينه صفوان ولا يزال
مصطفى الصفواني صابرا على هذا الفقد رغم
حزنه العميق الواضح على ملامحه المنهكى
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مدينه صفوا العربيه